Scientists regularly work with three-dimensional data,
from medical images like MRI scans
to maps of glaciers produced by lasers.
But most scientists use flat displays
like computer screens, which can’t
fully represent 3D datasets.
So researchers are looking for newer,
better ways to display 3D data.
Virtual and augmented reality systems, for example,
can display patients’ medical images
to help doctors better plan surgery
But 3D-printing can also be used
to print out physical, handheld copies of data.
These models can easily be shown to large groups
without VR headsets,
which make some people feel nauseous.
3D data needs to be converted into a computer model
before it is printed.
These models are made up of tiny,
connected triangles that cover its surface.
But this process can make for awkward images:
For example, MRI images of the fine white matter tracts
in the brain are converted into bulky tubes.
This kind of printing also has trouble creating objects where
where solid parts or data points
are separated by empty space.
Now, scientists have developed a method
called voxel printing, which allows high resolution
printing of 3D data without the need to
convert it into a computer model first.
The 3D dataset is sliced up into hundreds
of horizontal images, each made of thousands
of voxels, or three-dimensional pixels.
Each voxel is printed using droplets of colored resin
which are hardened with UV light.
Different resins can be combined to produce new colors
and a transparent resin is used
to represent empty space.
Each layer is printed out, one on top of the other,
to gradually build up a 3D structure.
Layers can be as thin as 12 microns.
The final, high-definition model
can contain billions of individual voxels.
So far the researchers have used their technique
to print out copies of tissue samples,
laser-scanned statues,
and topographical maps of the moon
The ability to faithfully reproduce 3D data
in a physical form could have a range of applications,
from conserving historical artifacts .
to helping patients understand their medical scans
The team says that they hope one day
scientists will be able to print off 3D datasets
with just the press of a button.